welcome to the MIT communications forum
we are speaker series that's produced
through the School of the Humanities
here at MIT we are free we are open to
the general public we do about six
events per year and we are always
extremely excited to see audiences come
in so let me give you guys kind of a
rundown of how this event will work how
all of our events work we're going to
have an hour of moderated discussion
focused on how to fight a Nazi and then
we'll have about an hour of audience
question and answer so think of some
good questions while we're talking we
have these two mics set up for whenever
you have questions when it's opened
audience Q&A please come up use one of
our microphones the event is being audio
and video recorded so be aware of that
if you would like to see more events
like this in the future please sign up
for our mailing list there's a sign-up
sheet right over there when the event is
over and otherwise welcome thank you
guys so much for being here let me
introduce myself as well as the speakers
my name is Christina couch I'm the
coordinator for the MIT communications
forum I'm also a science journalist and
a graduate of the MIT graduate program
science writing I actually did my thesis
work on the science of D radicalization
and a big part of that thesis which was
published in Nova next in 2015 focused
on this guy right here this is Christian
peach aleni he's a peace advocate and
author of this book white American youth
my descent into America's most violent
hate movement and how I got out if you
would like a copy of this book it's
actually on sale for 20% off at the MIT
coupe in 2009 Christian co-founded a
nonprofit group called life after hate
which is dedicated to helping
communities and organizations implement
long term solutions that counter racism
and violent extremism Christian
currently leads a group called the free
radicals project which is a global
network of extremist preventionists who
help people disengage from all sorts of
hate movements including white supremacy
as well as Isis potential school
shootings etc etc to just beyond is a
Leo run Corey kolinsky car landscape
excuse me
he's a Senior Program Officer for beyond
conflate
a non-profit research and consulting
group that applies lessons from brain
and behavioral sciences to address a
range of racial justice and inclusion
issues conflict resolution
reconciliation and other challenges
beyond conflicts current work includes
measuring psychological factors that
drive racism creating visual and
geographic maps that showcase
subconscious phenomena the drug conflict
and assessing at risk excuse me
assessing conflict and division in
at-risk communities and building
cognitive and behavioral science based
tools to decrease political polarization
within the United States that is
mouthful yeah so that should give you an
idea of kind of who's who we are and
what we're doing here first of all just
to give everybody an idea of the the
context for the panel I'd like to open
it up and we would both of you mind
talking a little bit about how you got
into the work of de-radicalization
because it is such a specific and a
fascinating field and kind of what would
you're doing right now you've either one
whoever feels comfortable um I've been
doing the work of trying to understand
and dismantle the white supremacist
movement for thirty years eight of those
years I was actually a member from 1987
to 1990 96 I was at 14 years old I was
recruited into America's first neo-nazi
skinhead group from 14 to 22 I actually
spent that was eight years involved in
the movement when it was starting out at
least the skinhead part of it I managed
to get out at 22 and it took me several
years after leaving to really understand
how to move forward I didn't know who I
was I had spent almost every one of my
formative years at least my teen years
in that movement and before that I
didn't know who I was but eventually
because of the compassion of those that
I thought I hated
they gave me the opportunity to really
kind of see a different perspective
rather than attacking me or you know
anything that they really could have
done that was negative they chose to
approach me and listen to me and that
was really the first time in my life I
had a meaningful conversation with the
people I thought I hated and it really
opened doors it certainly wasn't just
that one instance it was I had doubts
every day I was involved but it was like
a snowball and when I left I decided I
wanted to I wanted to help other people
other vulnerable young people who were
being duped by the same movement that I
helped build and and try to educate them
and offer them kind of a you know a
lifeline to get out if they wanted to so
I've been doing the work of
de-radicalization for about 15 years and
so far I've helped I think over 220
people disengage from hate groups and
groups like Isis and other extremist
groups as well thank you so I got into
the field of the radicalization or
radicalization actually through conflict
so I grew up in in Israel and grew up
around terrorism and Jerusalem during
the Second Intifada a group around the
difficult dynamics that happen when
large groups of people are mobilized to
fight one another including Allen and
when I came to the United States what I
wanted to learn and understand was how
do large groups of people come to fight
one another and how do individuals like
myself and my family members get
motivated to fight which again very
different context an ocean away but
maybe we'll be able to find some some
interesting commonalities about what
drives people to to that fight so while
Christians thinking about how do I get
individuals out of this
I'm thinking about how do we get groups
and movements and Nations to
quote-unquote decry the cause one of the
things that really interested me about
beyond conflict is you guys have a very
unique angle in terms of what goes on at
the beyond conflict innovation lab would
you mind breaking down a little bit
about sort of what types of initiatives
you guys run and and the science
component of what you do sure definitely
so beyond conflict is a 26 year old
organization we started working at the
end of the Cold War right around the
time I was born but what we've done is
worked in some of the most iconic
conflicts over the last 20 25 years so
the end of apartheid in South Africa we
helped initiate the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission the Good
Friday Agreement in Northern Ireland and
its implementation and most recently the
u.s. Cuba opening working with Cuban
Americans in Miami and also with the
Obama administration and elements of the
Cuban government but the basis for all
of that was this notion that there's a
shared human experience so what we did
is we brought leaders who have
successfully negotiated transition to
share their experience about what could
be done to move things forward and we
bring people like Christian who let's
say had some kind of epiphany new
understanding and would take them to to
meet people who are struggling with the
same challenges so very similar actually
to what you're doing right now and we
would do that on a global scale but what
we found is that there's now a science
behind this right there's a systematic
understanding of how humans think and
feel about themselves and about one
another and it would be irresponsible
for our field conflict resolution
reconciliation for ourselves in our call
is to not try and apply that in
thoughtful concrete ways and so five or
six years ago partly out of a series of
conferences here at MIT with the
political science department and the
cognitive and brain science department
we created this initiative which is now
a formal innovation lab house would then
be on conflict and or focused on for
psychological processes that we think
are critical building blocks so one is
social belonging and identity so how we
come to understand ourselves and our
groups and what does it mean to belong
the second is dehumanization and empathy
so how do we do humanize other groups
and how can we empathize with them the
third is the consequences of violence of
trauma violence and victimhood
and the fourth is how do you rebuild
social trust so those are the themes we
have and within that we have a number of
initiatives focused on racism and
exclusion polarization and the migrant
refugee crisis so one of the topics that
came up when the three of us spoke is
the radicalization many people have this
idea that radicalization happens to very
specific people but that it actually can
happen to kind of anyone I'd like to
unpack that a little bit because I know
when I say when I see things like the
unite the right rally and what goes on
in Charlottesville it is incredibly
difficult for me to feel any sort of any
degree of empathy for what's going on in
those types of circumstances would you
guys mind unpacking that a little bit
and talking about you know what is the
research show in this department what
what are your experiences doing
intervention show I don't know what
research shows because I'm not a
psychologist I do you know I have my own
research and and that's you know
hundreds if not thousands of people and
I can tell you that from my experience
ideology is not what's driving
radicalization it is in my opinion kind
of overlapping with what you said just
now it's an individual search for
identity community and purpose those are
three basic foundational human needs
that I think that everybody in their
lives looks for Who am I where do I
belong and what am I supposed to do with
my life if we hit what I call potholes
in our life's journey those things that
you know
could be trauma could be poverty it
could be privilege it could be mental
illness it could be anything really if
we don't have enough resources to
navigate those potholes or enough
resilience to be able to navigate them
they detour us and that can happen to
anybody it can happen to you know
somebody who's been abused their whole
lives and and you know is the
stereotypical person that you would
think would go into these movements or
it can happen to somebody like a Richard
Spencer who has extreme privilege and an
education and is bright and found his
way there so you know in my opinion what
I've seen is those potholes that trauma
that we experience whether it's you know
a lot of little ones or one really big
one tends to deviate our search for
identity community and purpose and when
we get detoured there are people waiting
for us who understand those
vulnerabilities in us and they're very
savvy at kind of tailoring their pitch
or their approach as I was at one point
of my life to understand for every
person what their potholes were so that
I could promise them paradise
essentially create some imaginary enemy
that would put their focused on them so
that they can project their own self
hatred onto them because really I do
believe that hatred in itself is is
really self hatred being projected like
could you talk a little bit about you
know what does research show about who
gets radicalized you know why why are
certain people you know attracted to
recognized extremist groups and and
others who have been through very
similar backgrounds you know have
absolutely no interest right that's a
big question so I think that probably
the most decisive factor that everyone
is kind of implicitly understood but
maybe worthwhile mentioning here is that
the the most likely category of people
to be radicalized our young men I think
that sometimes doesn't get acknowledged
but generally we're talking about men so
young men in the audience you're a risk
group the rest of you are not off the
hook so I think the a little bit of
history I think especially in the United
States after 9/11 there's a lot of
attention paid to terrorism and people
are trying to find what were the kind of
key ingredients that made people turn to
this particular ideology this particular
kind of behavior and it often focus on
poverty or kind of interest based
approaches so what is it that in their
lives that led these people that you
know they they had to fight poverty you
had to create they didn't have enough
jobs so those was kind of the the
initial perspective but then I think
what Christian was saying is is
absolutely right and let the research
show is that number one is need to
belong need to belong to a community and
a group that gives you meaning power
some sense apart in some sense of agency
and I think that there are structural
factors that sometimes impede that so
for instance in some of the work that
we're doing in the Middle East if people
young men grow up in authoritarian
environments where they don't have the
capacity to make decisions that affect
their own lives then that that increases
the risk of turning to extremism or
finding alternative sources of meaning
and group identity but it doesn't mean
that it doesn't happen in the West and I
think one group that sometimes was
vulnerable to it our second-generation
immigrants yeah that's a that's
interesting that you brought that up
because 25 percent 25 percent of
Americans under 20 years old are either
first generation or second generation
Americans that's a lot of identity
crisis you know one foot and you know
your parents world one foot and you know
the new world and and
trying to find a balance between both is
tough
just to maybe put it into perspective a
little bit when I was recruited
I was just that morning you know running
to the corner store with change to buy
baseball cards and Lemonheads I was 14
years old I had no idea about politics I
didn't understand racism although I'm
sure I was complicit and you know
institutional you know a privilege and
everything but I didn't learn it from my
parents my parents are Italian
immigrants who came to the United States
in the mid-60s so they were often
victims of prejudice it wasn't really
something that was taught to me at home
so you know for all intent and purpose I
should not have gone down that route
what happened to me one of my potholes
my main pothole was abandonment my
parents because they were immigrants had
to work seven days a week 15 hours a day
I never saw them and while they were
providing and they were you know they
loved me and you know I had aunts and
grandparents around me you know I was
never I never knew how to be vulnerable
enough to express my feelings I always
thought you know what did I do to push
them away so you know you start to act
out at a young age to try and get their
attention so you know when I said
earlier I kind of try to be that person
that I wish you know would have been
there for me I try and see the child in
everybody whether they're six or sixty
the broken child instead of the monster
because looking at them as monsters
makes them subhuman which is exactly
what they try and do to everybody else
and in fact the only thing I've ever
seen you know quote unquote break hate
is is is compassion and empathy and not
you know punching a Nazi we're worried
but do you feel the you know if if you
would grown up where and if your parents
are talking more about
race and expressing you know that not
everybody has the same chances within
the United States and having those early
honest conversations do you do you think
that you would have been deterred you
know I think it certainly would have
helped I never had those kinds of
conversations you know with my parents I
still haven't had like the
birds-and-the-bees talk with them
wondering like we can talk afternoon
I'll explain the whole thing to kids
already you know I think more than
telling me those things would be
exposing me to those things right you
know I have the silly idea that you know
we should really take our kids from the
day they're born to eat Indian food and
Japanese food and African food because
maybe if you know because they're
growing up eating chicken nuggets maybe
if they just aren't afraid of food
that's different they won't be afraid of
people that they think are different I
don't know it's little things like that
that I think we need to travel more we
need to read more we need to you know
experience more and ask a lot more
questions it's okay to ask questions you
know none of us in this room should feel
like we know everything about race
because none of us do and we're all no
matter how you know how tolerant or how
progressive we are we step in it and we
do things that we don't even know are
racist so you know I think that it's a
learning process and I think we just
have to be open to learning sorry did I
cut you off would you mind speaking a
little bit to sort of how it feels to be
inside one of these groups I mean
specifically you know when I when I was
interviewing you kind of constantly
throughout 2014 and 2015 I was really
shocked at how these groups recruit and
about you know once you're in the level
of isolation and really the emphasis on
love that happens within these groups
was truly shocking to me you know I
think like like drugs the first time the
first couple times you do it it was
amazing it fills you with the sense of
like you know I'm not talking about
drugs anymore I'm talking about the
movement but it gave me like this sense
of you know I am I'm not worthless
anymore now I feel you know I feel
self-worth even though of course it was
completely toxic you know I didn't have
a family or at least I felt like I
didn't now I did and there was something
to be said about the camaraderie they
really did deliver when it came to that
family you know kind of dynamic or that
that feeling of that perception of power
or respect but that goes away really
really quickly because it's just there
to pull you in once you're in you've
already abandoned everything that that
is out you know outside of that movement
so they know you can't really go back
you've already you know stigmatized
yourself you've already left your family
your hobbies your friends behind it's
like a cult you know what do you go back
to and oh by the way if you do decide to
go back not only do the people that
you're leaving hate you and want to kill
you your friends sometimes the only
people you've ever known but the rest of
the outside world still hates you
because you know you still are what you
were in their eyes so you know it's you
feel trapped and you know in a sense
you're being drawn into this group
because you feel marginalized already
and what joining these extremist groups
does is marginalize you even more so it
is very much like you know bad medicine
that you keep taking over and over and
over again because it makes you feel but
good for a shorter amount of time every
time you take it but you know if you
stop taking it
the alternative is even worse so that it
feels very much like what I would think
you know a drug addict would feel like
we're you know what you're doing is
terrible but you still need it to stay
alive can i maybe jump on this in group
love yeah I mean one of the one of the
critical factors that we see in the
tractable conflicts is that groups
there's a psychological process called
motive attribution asymmetry and what
that means is that we believe that our
group acts out of love for our own group
and protection and that then they're
acting out of hate and
we know that's that's not true because
if we believe that we're acting out of
love and then we'll probably are but it
seems to me that that kind of gets
distorted that normal psychological
process gets distorted in this context
where threat is heightened right so your
group is being attacked and so out of
love and empathy and compassion towards
your own group right that's bounded you
want to you're motivated to join in
enacting ways that our pursuit is people
in fact are I am I trying to excuse it
for eight years I thought I was saving
the world I mean I really I mean maybe
not all of those eight years cuz I had
doubts for many of those years but there
were points where I thought I was doing
the right thing and I couldn't
understand why everybody else didn't
understand so you know I really I
understand that because when we were
attacked I could not understand why we
were the subject of that attack and
everybody else you know kind of like
what's happening now I've you know all
Republicans are Nazis all liberals are
communists and you know both sides hey
each other and that I don't think that's
the case necessarily we really really
disagree with what either side is doing
but I think at the end of the day 99% of
the people we have an issue with we
would agree our Americans are you know
people that we wouldn't mind living in
the same neighborhood with if you know
if things were a little bit different
and you know I think that I agree with
what you said because it's it's really
important to understand that the people
in these movements really do believe
they're doing the right thing
so trying to convince them that they're
not is not really the best approach it
seems like this also dovetails with the
political polarization work that you're
doing as well I mean we are at a time
period where it is very difficult for
sides to talk to each other at least at
least for now I've realized that it has
always been difficult and that there
have always been factions but right now
it seems like political polarization at
least it feels particularly high first
of all is that the case in in terms of
you know how how this works in terms
doubling down it seems like that would
dovetail with political polarization as
well absolutely yeah and so that kind of
taken reverse order
political polarization is at a historic
high in the United States according to
most indicators it is the highest it's
been since the end of Reconstruction
higher than Vietnam yes by sitting by
kind of traditional political science
measures one of the things we're doing
is developing a polarization index a
giant track the underlying cognitive
factors that lead to this kind of
increased polarization and specifically
what we're focused on are things called
meta perceptions so not what I think
about you but what I think you think
about me which is a very strong
predictor of my perceptions of you which
ties very nicely to the love versus hate
I thinks that's self hatred thing I
think yeah you hate if you hate yourself
you expect other people will hate you so
you hate them first and there's a
there's also a little bit of that way if
you do something bad you kind of
anticipate that everyone else is also
doing that bad thing but anyways the the
other metric that we use is one of
blatant dehumanization and what we found
is that current dehumanization mutual
dehumanization of Republicans and
Democrats is very close to the mutual
dehumanization of Israelis and
Palestinians during the 2014 Gaza war
now there's no violence here but I think
you could ask different communities and
they would argue that point I guess I
would say there's no acute non
Republicans and Democrats private floor
right right we're not in those long
those group lines but I take your point
so I think that yes polarization is very
high and
think trying to break through that it's
gonna be a real challenge and I think
that polarization actually fuels a lot
of rise and extremism I think we're not
listening I think nobody is listening I
think everybody's talking you know we
say both sides have to talk to each
other well really both sides have to
listen to each other as well that's also
part of communication and I don't know
that we're listening to the finer points
because we're all kind of up here which
you know certainly there are instances
where you know I would say yeah it's not
something I want to listen to but no I
mean but at the end of the day we're all
human beings who you know I kind of at
our core want the same things we want to
be healthy we want our families to be
healthy and fed and have jobs and be
successful and happy I feel like we're
being forced to choose sides right now
or at least maybe we're self separating
for you know whatever reason the truth
is is we all kind of live in the middle
we don't live on the extremes at least
we didn't you know maybe three years ago
I think to get to the middle we have to
start with those points that we have in
common with each other
we'll go off track but we'll have
something to come back to if we start
with those points that we have you know
that are differing all the time we'll
never find that commonality to get back
to and maybe that's a really simplistic
view but I think it's it's also a really
practical one I mean one thing that I do
when I work with people is I don't
debate them I don't argue with them I
don't tell them that they're wrong I
want to but I don't
instead I listen because eventually
after I listened enough I start to hear
what they're really saying and sometimes
they don't even know exactly that
they're saying it but I'm able to filter
out the noise one because I used to say
it so you know kind of just goes right
past me and sound it makes me think like
I you know I used to say that when I'm
14 you shouldn't really be saying that
at 30
wherever but I'm able to kind of like
pinpoint those nuggets of Informatics
you know I'm able to understand what the
potholes are by listening and that tells
me the whole story not what's coming out
of their mouth I think to really hear
what somebody's saying it's not about
listening to their words it's about kind
of paying attention to everything else
we're in a time right now where I feel
like even having the conversation of you
know can we come to agreement on some
common ground issues even just having
the camera but it's not about common
ground okay it's about listening to
people it's not about settling it's not
about appeasing them it's not about
endorsing their ideas it has nothing to
do with that we're just seeing so many
communities that are experiencing
legitimate fear and violence right now
and to see those communities you know
having these just fighting for their
humanity is a is a difficult and
horrifying thing to sort of watch happen
day after day after day
and so that brings us to another
question this is one that sort of been
much debated over the past many months
should you punch a Nazi I have to admit
when I saw the video of Richard Spencer
who's a very well-known white
nationalist
somebody punched him in the face the
video went viral I found it
satisfying to a degree that I don't even
have words for it would seem like
according to your research and work
maybe punching a Nazi is not the most
effective means of breaking people from
from extremism so would you mind walking
me through what are the effective means
what's what's a better strategy well it
depends what you're hoping to achieve if
you're hoping to get emotional
satisfaction and it seems like that may
be the right thing to do
it may not be strategically wise so one
when thinking about that question I
often think to my colleagues at the
African National Congress which is
Nelson Mandela's movement and the
current ruling party in South Africa we
often bring them around the world to
speak with other opposition movements
and and they often say be strategically
wise and avoid the easy emotionally
satisfying victories so I think the
question is what are you hoping to
achieve by by by doing the punching and
I think there is a real tension here
between mobilizing your supporters and
energizing them and trying to reach out
and persuade the other side so if you're
trying to persuade someone to abandon
their views punching them generally it's
is not going to be a very effective
strategy Sharpe but if you're trying to
mobilize your supporters and galvanize
them then maybe that is although I
personally would not recommend it gotta
take a crack at it I'm gonna tell you a
secret there are two things that Nazis
or any extremists love silence and
violence yeah if we're silent if we
ignore them they grow if we continue to
pretend like we're living in a
post-racial society and sweep it under
the rug if we continue to think that
they're not a threat they're just going
to grow because you know they'll find an
ecosystem to grow in if we're violent we
play right into their hands because that
is what they want to accomplish when
they go into always very liberal towns
like Skokie Illinois which is a Jewish
neighborhood in the 1970s in Illinois
that's why they went to Charlottesville
that's why they went to Berkeley that's
why they came to Boston all the Boston
good job I have to say I want to talk
about
but that's their goal because when we
are violent against them they use that
against us they become the victim they
now have ammunition to say you see how
we were attacked you see how our free
speech was squashed how you know how
people are intolerant against us they
hate us
we're not the haters it's a tactic they
go in knowing that there's going to be
violence they go in knowing that they're
gonna say the most egregious things
carry the worst you know signs say you
know they go there intending to be
attacked because that helps them so to
that I would say Boston good job because
what happened in Charlottesville where
people were punching each other and of
course a young woman lost her life at
the end of the day at the hands of a
white nationalist but when they tried to
do that here in Boston you guys gave the
best response that could ever be
imagined there were a couple of dozen
neo-nazis that gathered just a few weeks
after Charlottesville and I think it was
reported that 20,000 people from Boston
came out and surrounded them there was
not one arrest there was not one fight
that I'm aware of there was no you know
it wasn't a mela it wasn't any kind of a
fight I guarantee you they'll not come
back here they won't try that again but
they will try to go back to
Charlottesville they will try to go back
to Berkley because they know that it
worked
so you know when it comes to I don't
know any Nazi in the history of earth
that ever changed his views because he
got punched Richard Spencer is not less
of a Nazi and you know I agree with with
Lee or said you know if you want
personal satisfaction if that makes you
feel good if that's what you want to do
do it but then look in the mirror and
say am i any different than that person
that I just punched when you do an
intervention with somebody who is
leaving an extremist group whether it's
a white supremacist group or otherwise
can you sort of walk me through what
your basic steps are what you're what
you're looking for and what the actual
work
doing an intervention looks like I've
learned to sum it up in seven words that
start with L great very concise first
you link with them you have to establish
rapport all right and you listen and
you're listening for those potholes all
right now I'm going to screw them up
lift link there sorry the next one is
leverage so you leverage whatever
resources you have to build that
resilience the next step for me is once
I feel that they're in a place where
they're back to reality they're being
vulnerable the next one is lift and I'll
introduce them to the people that they
think that they hate I've spent hours
with Holocaust deniers and Holocaust
survivors you know Islamophobes and and
and whoops limbs or Imams and you know
homophobes and LGBTQ community and vice
versa because it happened to me I
finally had the opportunity to have that
meaningful dialogue but it also happened
to all the other people that I didn't
help that got out they finally met
somebody that completely challenged the
demonization that was happening in their
head and all of a sudden it turned into
humanization that I can't hate that
person anymore because even though we're
not exactly alike we're more alike than
I care to think about so all of a sudden
you can't demonize that person and it's
like a healthy cognitive dissonance
right so you it starts to expand and
then the Latin and the last two are love
so they need a new identity a new
community a new purpose you have to give
them that aftercare and then the last
one is live that's when they're kind of
that free radical and they can you know
take what they've learned and and be
human again but it's it's it's a long
process all right it's different for
everybody as part of that you know
leverage and and lift part of the ELLs
it's it's about finding people who can
help build resilience job trainer
psychologists
you know tattoo removal tattoo cover-ups
you name it whatever it is life coaches
that people need to become more
resilient it's pretty amazing what
happens when you suddenly have the
skills and the tools to be confident the
need to blame other people for taking
something away from you
imaginary or real it kind of goes away
because now you have the tools that you
need and you don't need to blame
somebody else for what you think is
being taken away so that's kind of so
linked listen leverage lift love live
that's six I'm missing one but it's in
there it rounds out six rounds up to 17
Lyra can you walk us through a little
bit about what is the actual work of
creating an effective piece building
strategy look like what are the steps
what goes into it sure yeah well it
depends on the context obviously but I
think the I think what would be the best
way to related to some of this work but
I guess the the first thing is to
identify the relevant identity groups
which i think is similar to what you're
doing right so what are the key
stakeholder are the relevant meaningful
communities that you need to engage with
so in the context of the us-cuba opening
it was clear that the cuban-american
community because of their history with
the island was a really important
community to engage with so where the
relevant stakeholders from a group
perspective and then you need to
understand what values drive them what
narratives drive them what ideologies
and what what kind of core human
motivations like need to belong need to
survive things like that and then once
you start engaging like what I love
about the seven hells is that so
six habit the contact part right that
where you actually bring often people
think that conflict resolution is just
bringing people together who hate each
other but actually the the pre-work is
the critical part because like we talked
about earlier it's my understanding of
Who I am in my place in the group and my
need to belong that really matters and
if you immediately jump into the contact
into the as you call the love part it
could really backfire and people are
just not ready for it so a lot of the
work that an effective large-scale
conflict resolution intervention does is
actually not bringing groups together
it's preparing groups to be brought
together and that's I think that's been
borne out by some of the research that
have been a great reason for those of
you who like this kind of stuff
meta-analysis done by Betsy levy palek
about contact theory that's the name of
what I just described so bringing
different groups together and the record
is really really mixed especially when
it comes to adults around issues of race
ethnicity and Prejudice like that I call
it immersion but one of the technology
has certainly played this really
critical role in both recruiting and
providing a platform for people who are
victims of extremist groups to have a
larger voice than they might have
otherwise there's also been a lot of
conversations with in tech circles about
the morality of deep platforming
extremists so that might be kicking
somebody off of a social media platform
like Twitter or a payment platform what
PayPal or podcasting platform can you
speak a little bit to the sort of tech
aspect of this one one thing that when
you and I were talking I was really
interested in that there are white
supremacist recruitment tools embedded
in video games and you had mentioned
communities of people with autism are
particularly targeted for this type of
thing first of all would you mind
speaking to the role that technology
plays in getting people involved and
whether you feel like the platforming is
a is a viable
tool for getting the extremists out yeah
so the internet back in my day was very
much kind of an in-person recruitment
right you get a pamphlet you get a book
you meet somebody you go to a meeting
nowadays the Internet is is that
platform and of course you know there's
so much information on the Internet and
it's such a great tool that it's also
you know can be used as a bad tool and
can have tons of disinformation we've
all heard the term fake news I'm sure
we're tired of hearing about it I can
tell you it exists and I can tell you
there's a lot of it I can also tell you
a lot of it is coming from Russia just
because of people that I've worked with
who it's a long story
but it has really created this place so
you know if we think about marginalized
people marginalized young people who are
being drawn to these movements for that
identity community and purpose
oftentimes these marginalized people
don't have very many friends in real
life so they live online and when
they're online they can be whoever they
want to be they don't have to be
worthless or weak online they can be a
hero
and they've gravitated to these because
of the disinformation and fake news
that's kind of brought them there
they've gravitated to these websites
that are you know white nationalist or
Isis or whatever and while they're there
there are people who are kind of you
know skimming the water and recruiting
these people more proactively what
they're doing is they're going to places
where they know marginalized people
gather so you know a large number of
video gamers you know might live
exclusively online that might be their
world so they're going to those places
where they you know can anticipate that
a good percentage doesn't have a social
network outside of the internet they're
also going to video games and it's not
so much the tools are embedded in the
but you know those headsets that you're
doing online gaming I get reports every
day of young parents contacting me
saying you know I had some neo-nazi from
Estonia trying to recruit my
twelve-year-old or you know when my son
was in this game I was watching him
playing and you know the other person's
avatar was like a Nazi and his name was
like you know Himmler SS or something
like that and the man when I asked my
son what he was saying they were talking
about the Holocaust
I mean it's just they're going to places
where they know that vulnerable people
are safe zones where they can expect to
be safe but now they're not anymore and
that's one of the things that they're
doing but yeah the internet really has
kind of created this platform you know
for information whether it's real or not
to spread and for us to not really be
able to distinguish between the two and
that has really done a disservice and
you know frankly I mentioned Russia
earlier but the truth is and I think
most people don't know this but since
the early 1900's since 1903 Russia has
been involved in this kind of
disinformation war this conspiracy
theory war one of the earliest and most
influential pieces of conspiracy theory
and fake and fake news or disinformation
is a book called the learned protocol or
the the protocols of the learned Elders
of Zion it is an anti-semitic book that
Russia published under the guise that it
was a leaked document from like a secret
Jewish meeting of world leaders who were
planning on taking over the world that
book today even a hundred and twenty
years later is still the most
influential book for neo-nazis and for
Isis who are both by the way very
anti-semitic back anti-vaccine stuff
Flat Earth stuff if you've heard any of
those conspiracy theories they all came
out of Russia between 1903 and today and
their goal is to just kind of give all
this misinformation disinformation when
we spread it it's misinformation so that
we have absolutely no grounding and
reality
so we're fighting with each other what I
saw happen it was a girl that I was
working with I noticed this was before
the election in 2016 but tens of
thousands of these kind of pro Trump
neo-nazi Twitter accounts and I started
being attacked by them because I was
working with a girl who was kind of part
of their circle and what I discovered
and turned over to the FBI in October of
2016 before the election was that they
were Russian trolls setting these
accounts up and that they were doing so
and I didn't know what the hell it was
but they were doing something to
influence the election and I turned that
over in October 2016 and I still have
not gotten a call back i sat with them I
handed over a harddrive of 32 gigs of
information of all the accounts of
everything and it wasn't until four
months later that we actually heard on
the news you know we suspect that
Russian meddling has happened in the
election and it's like are you trying to
tell me that this administration was not
on the ball about that issue I'm not
sure I believe that Laura could you
speak a little bit to when we talk about
D platform or essentially taking away
these tools that extremist groups can
use is the platforming you know in in
both of your opinions an effective way
of sort of curtailing some of this
extremist issues or you know does it
just send them underground and remove a
tool that you know other people could
use to keep track of these groups so the
if I I like to kind of compare these two
approaches to the latter is that
sunshine is the best disinfectant right
area of let's hear out the views and and
then we can counter them and the second
is rooted in the belief that if you if
you give these individuals a platform
then it amplifies their message I think
the way I like to think about that is
thinking about social norms and the
impact that social norms have on human
being
and especially what's called descriptive
norms so what's what we see other
members of our group doing and I think
that descriptive norms have a tremendous
amount of power and platforming people
provides and with a great amount of
power so if it if something is perceived
as normal it can have a tremendous
amount of influence in furthering
recruitment so I think that limiting
that perception is the key right so if
you if you don't make these kinds of
messages appear normal then you can have
a greater impact so with that I think is
the principle I would take the specific
decision I think it really varies by
institution in context and so I don't
have any particular set of guidelines on
that that I have you know I think that
free speech does not apply in these
cases because it doesn't apply
I mean free speech only really applies
when it's between us in the government
it does not apply when we're talking
about a public company who can do
whatever they want and doesn't have to
protect free speech and I kind of look
at it like an apartment building if you
had one tenant out of the 20 apartments
that was you know constantly starting
fires letting their dog out of the
apartment let letting it poop in the
hallways not paying the rent
you know attacking the other tenants I
think it's that pert that company's
responsibility that platforms
responsibility to to eliminate that
person from the platform however you
know things have circumstances that we
don't always anticipate so what's
happened now that we've started the D
platform you know people is they've gone
and they've created their own
technologies things like gab and you
know and hey Treon it's such a good pun
for such a bad well he just got arrested
for you know
child pornography so you can tell the
caliper that are still around you know
it doesn't it doesn't stop them it may
you know put a little bit of a speed
bump in the road for them and I and I
agree that it's you know if it benefits
the full community they should probably
not be there but it doesn't I mean don't
be under any kind of like you know
illusion that it stops them it doesn't
they just find ways to go underground
and it goes back to that whole silence
and violence if we don't see them have
they gone away not really
I've only got one more question left
after that we're gonna open it up to
audience questions once again these are
the two microphones please come and use
them so that we can have good audio for
when we put it up on the web and we're
gonna go sort of back and forth we'll
start at this one and then we'll kind of
alternate here there so be aware that's
how we're gonna do things you know in
your opinion can you tell me a little
bit about what needs to happen on either
a governmental or societal level in
order to to really effectively reduce
radicalism and do are there policies or
programs in place that that YouTube view
as being either particularly effective
or just completely ineffective well I
think one one thing I think is is
Christian what you're doing right so I
think long term accompaniment and
engagement on an individual level from
what I've seen has proven to be very
effective much more than many other
things I think on a systemic level on a
governmental level you have to really
think hard about what makes young people
have meaning in their lives particularly
young men and I think that to me that
that should be the critical focus of the
government so how do you create or
non-governmental actors or irrelevant
right so how do you create meaningful
youth programs how do you give people
young people young men agency and some
sense of power of their own lives in a
way
won't be distorted to me that that would
be a critical thing and I don't see that
happening in any place around the world
you know I think without diminishing the
role of young men I think we're really
failing everybody else besides young men
and we've been doing that forever you
know and I think we're failing all of
our young people I don't think that
adults know how to be vulnerable with
young people and in turn they will never
be vulnerable with us if we can't talk
to our children or our students or our
players about what is really going on
with us
nothing never learn how to do that with
us they think we're superheroes you know
kids growing up think my parents you
know weren't around and I still you know
like I wanted them to be because I
looked up to them so I think that that's
you know not systemic Lee speaking but
from a personal level that's I think one
thing that we need to do is we need to
learn I call it cautious vulnerability
it's not about just opening everything
up it's about really just being very
intentional about it from a systemic
level in an institutional level I think
we need to fix the education system I
think we need to fix the prison system
and we think and we need to fix law
enforcement because even though that
doesn't affect the white community as as
much as it affects the african-american
community it's a cycle and until it
really is an equal place for everybody
and that institutional racism is gone we
can't expect interpersonal racism to go
away so it really kind of has to be an
overhaul we have to sit back and and ask
ourselves what is America it's not the
same you know we shouldn't have the same
vision that our grandparents had or you
know our forefathers you know we need to
sit down and really answer that question
about what it is if we're gonna move
forward because it seems like everything
we're doing is looking backwards make
America great again let's go back to you
we need to really think about what it is
that we're doing going forward okay
that seems like a good place to start
some audience questions if you have any
questions please come to the microphones
I want to thank both of you for lasting
a full hour through my questions
personally we'll start over here hello
hi thank you thank you for the great
talk so I have a question for Christian
I wonder if you can describe what your
customer acquisition process looks like
do you let people come to your door or
do you kind of actively
in my tea frame you know I may be the
only person on earth that cannot wait to
be out of a job
you know I've I've not outside of a
couple of people like Richard Spencer
who I've sat and talked with for a
couple of hours and other folks I've
never had to seek anybody out the amount
of people coming to me is overwhelming
so yeah I don't really have a problem
with that I wish I did to be honest but
I you know if I look at my phone now
there'll be somebody and they always
started the emails always start out I
need your help is it people who are
within radical groups coming to you
directly or do you also get contact from
friends or family members who are
worried about somebody it's it's split
almost equally in three ways the first
group is the person who's in an
extremist group and once help getting
out or starting to have confusion the
second group is what I call the
bystander family member friend
girlfriend boyfriend teacher whatever
and then the third is the former the
person who got out on their own could be
five years ago could be 15 years ago but
in many cases they've never in their
lives been able to speak it out loud and
that's traumatic to be able to you know
they have to hold you know even though
you're a better person you've found your
way out and you've been living a good
life
there are people whose wives don't know
or whose friends don't know and they're
not able to talk about that and it's a
very important part of the process to be
able to talk about it so for them we
really provide kind of like a support
network it's a virtual network you know
with a hundred people who are farmers
who kind of have like you know this very
cool group dynamic thank you for your
question there was a lot of controversy
over the statements he made about James
d'amour and the waking up podcast well a
while ago that I'm sure you don't want
to trudge into again would you mind
telling everybody who James dumore is in
case they're not familiar with that
particular case should I say derp do you
want to say ah he is the guy who came
out with a Google memo back in July of
2017 in August of 2017 regarding gender
differences and the difference between
whether it was an institutional cause
that's causing the gender gap in tech or
whether it's biological and it was it's
highly I know you had a lot of flack
because of how debatable it was as to
whether he did have allegiances to these
other more than hateful ideologies so in
light of your whole idea of compassion
what is the best way to firmly call
people out if it's not entirely obvious
that they're there that's a good
question
so just to give you a little bit more
background I was on a podcast with an
individual named Sam Harris and this
came up and and when James d'amours name
came up
it was pretty recently after that
happened the first several podcast first
three podcast that he did after he was
let go by Google were all right podcasts
since I made that statement I've
actually had a chance to talk to James
d'amour and my opinion has changed a
little bit I think that he genuinely did
not know that he was going on all right
podcasts however I still disagree with
what he said in his memo I said you know
I think that his claim is based on kind
of flawed logic as far as compassion
goes I mean I I have compassion for
everybody I mean I sit across from guys
would swastikas on their face
you know most of the time and and I have
to you know I'm I'm not reaching across
and you know yanking him out of their
chair and I listen to them I am I never
claimed that I'm a hundred percent right
because I know I've not been a hundred
percent right in my life but when it
comes to the statement I did get a lot
of flack over that but I also think
people didn't understand the nuance of
what he was doing like I did when I saw
him going on these kind of very
borderline alright podcasts to me you
know people could talk about dog whistle
it wasn't a dog whistle to me it was
like a bull horn like I to me they're
very blatantly white supremacists
podcast or not you know borderline
alright podcasts how would you approach
somebody that you think asked them
instead of attacking them you know if
they say yes then yeah if they say no
then they're probably and you think that
they are it could because they're
ashamed of being a part of it and that
gives you an in to talk to them of
course we're happy to repeat the
question
maybe think about the question of the
ladies podcast when they talk which
people say recruit what's their basic
message that they use to get people
they make equalization of Rights feel
like oppression it's not about things
equalizing it's about something being
taken away from me yeah right it's a
whole notion of privilege and you say to
some people you're like you know white
privilege nearly I don't have it my
parents worked hard that's not what
we're talking about the what we're
talking about is you don't have to worry
about your life every time you walk out
the door you know it's really about
taking these these you know vile ideas
and sanitizing them it's not about
saying white power it's about saying
white pride it's not about saying you
know we must secure the existence of our
people and a future for white children
it's about saying it's okay to be white
and it's really about taking these very
you know these messages that are you
know very recognizable and very
offensive and making them taking them
into a gray area where you can say okay
well that that's free speech and he's
not really saying he denies the
Holocaust he's saying he questions it or
he's skeptical it's like you know
they've learned how to massage their
words and make them more palatable you
know when I heard blood and soil we all
heard that a million times from the
Charlottesville rally
well that translated to me as race and
nation because that's the same slogan
that we used to say 30 years ago they
took the word race out of it and they
just made it blood and soil right and
it's just that like polishing of it that
makes it less offensive on the surface
but when you really think about it I
mean obviously what they're talking
about is white power and white homeland
so you know just be very sensitive to
the fact that they're not going to hit
you with the most blatant you know
message that's they know we recognize
that thirty years ago there's this whole
concept that we did called boots to
suits right we knew that the boots and
the tattoos and the shaved heads in the
Swat
because we're turning away even the
average American white racist it's true
even you know grandpa Stan who you know
who hates everybody would see a Nazi
walking down a street and hate that Nazi
well the minute we took off the Nazi
uniforms and we became just like grandpa
Stan and sure to use words that he used
well then it wasn't so hard for him to
bite we encourage people to not shave
their heads not get tattoos we encourage
them to go into law enforcement to go
into the military if they had a clean
record to run for office to be teachers
to really kind of infect from within
economy babies the job they have made me
through treatment five people and basic
messages but you want
you know I think in most cases it's more
personal than that it's less about who's
not having a job and it's more about you
know what somebody did to you when you
were three you know there are lots of
people out of a job and they don't
become Nazis yeah right but there are
lots of people who've been abused in
their lives you've suffered trauma who
end up becoming drug addicts or who join
a cult or who are strong enough to go
find help and get it because maybe they
have access to it but not everybody does
and you know honestly if we need to fix
something healthcare is the big one
because there are 75% of the people I
deal with are suffering from a mental
disorder whether it's autism or
schizophrenia or bipolar or you know
chronic depression and I'll come you
know a lot of that comes from from the
trauma so you know I think that
healthcare we need to focus on young
people and you know we really need to
amplify people's passions at the
earliest age possible because it's
hopelessness I think and an uncertainty
that really pushes people to these
movements so if any of those things that
you said would cause uncertainty then it
certainly that person would be you know
right for some sort of radicalization
whether it's you know promiscuity or
drugs or a Nazi or Isis or whatever I
mean our radical yeah because they're
providing everything that's missing in
their life because it's the recruiters
job to find out what that is
oh you feel abandoned we're your family
that guy abused you well we're against
that and we're not going to we're gonna
make sure that doesn't happen to you
again it's really you know it's all
these kind of empty promises that never
come to fruition the way I look at it is
there are three stages there's the pre
radicalization stage and we're all
susceptible to this the radicalization
stage and then the D radicalization
stage and even after that there's
aftercare but we start to become pre
radicalized the day were born and it has
nothing to do with ideology the ideology
just presents itself and it becomes the
permission
slip for you to be angry that's what
allowed somebody like me at 14 years old
to say yeah
Hitler good guy I hadn't didn't even
hadn't even studying it in school I
didn't even know it it's the pits the
license somebody's finally saying you
know what you're angry go have fun
because those are all the people that
have you know that have held you down
your whole life it's just about so and
the leaders you know like it's all about
manipulation for them it's like a game
it's you know half of them are
sociopaths the other half are you know
narcissists and if there were the third
half they'd all be you know
megalomaniacs or something but it really
is about them using people who are
vulnerable so you know when I look at
those people in Charlottesville and I
hear at first when I heard you know very
fine people on both sides I was like no
but then I thought I have to believe
there are very fine people on both sides
otherwise I'd be denying myself my own
change I have to believe that there are
good people there that's such a bitter
pill there's a bitter hard pill to
swallow Leah I want to tag into you for
a minute
these recruitment strategies that
Kristen's talking about how does that
compare to the groups that beyond
conflict works with I think it's very
consistent right so the leadership so
it's a strategy and they probably have a
as I said a set of numbers they're
trying to hit right we need to have you
know X more people and this unit or that
unit and there were incentives yeah I
mean it's not like you know unlike any
other kind of like pyramid scam you know
marketing company that you get hired for
you know eight bucks an hour or
something like their incentives and then
you you just the recruiters are really
adept at preying on people's
vulnerabilities and the specific ones
that that Christian mentioned I think
are spot-on I think in the case of the
one that kind of cuts across is the need
need from
longing right need to belong need to
belong to a group and they give that and
they're very effective and they tap into
social networks whether online or in
person I mean who doesn't want to belong
every single person on earth wants to be
loved or accepted or respected it's
pretty easy to identify the people that
don't belong yes it's pretty easy to
promise them things that make them feel
better about themselves I kind of feel
like I'm still a recruiter like I'm
still looking for vulnerable people
except I'm kind of offering them
something better now I'm still looking
for those broken don't lead with that
lets someone get to know yours
hi thank you so much for sharing your
story and shedding insight and for your
vulnerability I'm actually a journalist
and I've talked to a lot of young earth
creationists who come to embrace
evolutionary science obviously a bit
different but I'm always really curious
about kind of their first moment when
they had that confusion you were talking
about so my questions the opposite of
the past question about how people are
persuaded to join I was wondering in
your experience what are some of those
moments or experiences that get people
to that cognitive dissonance that make
them come to you I'll tell you a very
specific story about an individual that
I worked with his name was Daryl he's
from Buffalo 31 and and when he
contacted me he was a wounded military
veteran that never actually made it to
the battlefield he got wounded in
training before he shipped out and he
was very angry now this is a guy who
when I asked him like you know if I were
to ask him what his potholes were he
wouldn't know what to say but when I
listened to him the things he said were
like I discovered my dad committed
suicide at nine and I was I was the one
who walked in on him and and I got
hooked on drugs at 12 and I you know at
14 you know I lived on the streets in it
and it's like yeah you want to tell me
more potholes and he was like but huh
what didn't even face him like he didn't
even know that that's what broke him
so what I'd any he came back and of
course in
military he was recruited because there
are a lot of you know people recruiting
in the military neo-nazis anyway and and
of course the military training itself
also taught him to hate that person over
there with the brown skin because that's
the war they were in so he came back
really angry he couldn't go kill Muslims
and somebody gave him a copy of my book
and and and he contacted me and he was
really angry at me you didn't like the
way the book ended because I got out you
know and and talked to him for a couple
of weeks and one day it was a really
funny guy but one day he was you know
just talking to me he's like I was in
the park and I was pushing my daughter
in a stroller and I was walking the dog
and I saw a Muslim man praying in the
park and and all I wanted to do was like
kick him first thing I asked him was I
sure wasn't somebody doing yoga because
he's very possible because he was far
away and the second thing I said is what
are you doing tomorrow because I'm
flying the Buffalo we need to sit down
and talk and I did I flew off the
Buffalo and one of the first questions I
asked him was you know Daryl have you
ever have you ever met a Muslim before
and he said no why would I want to
they're evil they want to kill me
bla bla you know and I said okay and I
normally don't do this but I usually
have some setup but what I did was I
excused myself I went to the bathroom
and I got out my phone and and I googled
the local mosque and very quietly I
talked to the Imam and I said Imam I
have a man here he's Christian but he
really would love to learn more about
you religion do you mind if we stop by I
don't normally do it that way but I felt
comfortable enough that he you know it
wasn't gonna you know be a bad
experience so I told him I told Darryl
we were going to lunch and and halfway
to where we were going for lunch I told
him we had to make a pit stop and and I
told him where we were going and I've
never seen anybody turn white so fast
and normally for somebody like him that
probably would have been a compliment
but literally like he went blank
and he got sick and he started sweating
and he wanted to vomit
and I pulled over and you know we talked
back and forth and I took us like 30
minutes to just calm him down to the
point where he can say a sentence and
after a while you know I said Darryl you
don't have to go if you don't want to
but I came out here you know for you I
said just walk through the doors with me
and if you don't want to stay after you
do that I'll walk out with you it's fine
and eventually we got there and knocked
on the the door of the mosque and the
Imam answered and he said you know
you're late I've only got 15 minutes you
know we had an hour scheduled and he's
like I have to prepare for a prayer
service but come on in 15 minutes that's
all you got two and a half hours later
after sitting around a conference table
you know talking understanding oh jesus
is in the Quran oh he never knew that I
mean it's like the ignorance and
isolation completely like cut him off
and you know before you know it they're
like hugging and crying and bonding over
Chuck Norris for some strange reason I
don't know why but they both loved Chuck
Norris I did not plan that he can do
anything but now Darrell goes there any
volunteers and he sets up chaired he's
still a Christian I mean like he goes
there with his wife and his kid and
there's not like a Friday you can drive
past her block and not see him eating
falafels together and it was really just
like that that connection you know I
always say that hatred is born of
ignorance fear is its father and
isolation is its mother he was afraid of
what he didn't understand and he'd been
isolated from it his whole life when I
was six a garter snake ran over my foot
I have been terrified of snakes since
then that's kind of what happened him
like he had he developed this phobia
almost and and until he was actually
able to hold you know the snake and see
it wasn't gonna bite him you know that's
what really made him realize that oh
okay and of course there's a lot more to
it but that was like one experience of
that that was healthy you know
yeah we're gonna take one more question
over here you've been waiting a good bit
if you make a quick maybe we'll squeeze
to it oh we're gonna get to you we're
coming over to that side immediately
I'll try to make this week thank you all
and actually speaking of the it's okay
to be white
posters I I just think it's like it's if
I may just be as an example it seemed to
not be the PI the poster that
radicalized young white man it's like
the reaction and that was by design like
in many instances people lost their
marbles and all this hate speech and
call this and that that very benign you
know statement became like a young
manhood was like it's not okay to be
white or if you if you think it's okay
to be white you're not see it's a how
and things like this like the Russian
you know IRA planting on both sides of
the political divide planting the most
extreme statement so that each side can
think the other side is much more
extreme than it really is what's
happening is well first of all the
far-right or the Nazis are coming with
the it's okay to be white science
because like I said they know it's a
gray area of course what are you gonna
tell somebody no it's not okay to be
white of course it's okay to be white
it's okay to be anything that you're
born as but what that does is it starts
that conversate Satrapi because now it's
the same thing with white lives matter
right try telling somebody that white
lives don't matter and and you will have
an argument with them but if you
understand that the reason that started
was intentionally to have that very
awkward conversation that was a trap
then you know so how can how can so like
college administration's or whoever
respond to these call them out as the
dog whistles they are or the totaling
attempts that they are without sending
that message it's hard you know I think
I get asked this question a lot you know
what do we do on college campuses when
this happens and I really don't know the
answer the only thing I could say is I
used to have a different opinion on hate
speech right first of all there's no
such thing as hate speech it's not a law
there's free
speech and that's it and I started to
think to myself like you know we need to
start controlling what these people say
because it's hurting people it's you
know online hate crimes are the same as
real hate crimes and then I started to
think you know really free speech and
that power is all about the
interpretation of who is in power what
happens when somebody doesn't like what
black lives matter says or what auntie
feh says or what women say can they then
use that same limitation of speech to
oppress them you know what I'm saying
we have to be careful because things
have unintended consequences just
because we don't like what somebody else
says and we have the power to change
that doesn't mean we will always hold
the power and sometimes we may be the
victims of that so I've really changed
my opinion on that and and I really do
think that we need more speech we need
education we need experience not less of
it so that was kind of kind of a
revelation that I had fairly recently
actually with the groups that the your
team deals with do you see this strategy
of a message that on very superficial
value seems like it's okay actually you
know do you see this this type of like
dog-whistle messaging as well yes I mean
I think the one element that Christian
about is about you guys can crosstalk
it's really okay it's about humor and
recruiting because that's one thing you
definitely see any internationally but I
think particularly here it's really
important right so the ambiguous humor
or the ambiguous that tire is a gray
area right yeah you know is it satire or
is it you know somebody really being
offensive
it's those gray areas they like to hide
so I guess what I what I wanted to ask
you and I think it relates to to this
question is how do you take those
ambiguous messages and and what would be
a good strategy to because I think it
relates to the deep platforming question
as well right what would be in general a
good strategy with one idea
is to just did what you just did which
is to explain to people this is what
it's meant to do this is the exact
strategy and kind of lay that out for
people to understand so what do you
think about that well I mean it's a
thing there's a thing called mimetic
warfare which is the use of means to get
ideas right so it's effective it works
you know they do they do use I mean the
alt-right does it all the time you know
Pepe the Frog and they use satire to
hide behind their races I'm kind of the
same way that you know a lot of you know
far-right political people hide behind
patriotism to hide their racism you know
education is important we need to
educate people because just saying hey
you can't put that up does not change
the problem it just puts a bandaid on it
but I also you know I think we need to
think about it a little in a little bit
more of a granular way and I've been
starting to think about this because 75%
of the people that I work with have
mental health disorders one of the
things that you know it's said about
people who are on the autism spectrum or
who have you know what what's called
Asperger's is unit dimensional thinking
kind of black and white thinking hyper
focus and and I don't know if I agree
with us or not because it's disputed but
a lack of empathy and not being able to
tell like nonverbal like to tell when
somebody's telling a joke so a lot of
those memes that are meant to be jokes
may not actually be jokes to some people
they may not understand that it's
offensive they may not understand that
you know what they're spreading and I
think I mean they even call them they
call it weaponized autism I am NOT
making this up
they have they're very proud of this
they're very it's a badge of honor for
them so it would not surprise me you
know and I certainly don't want to
generalize because I'm not you
I don't know enough about it but it
would not surprise me if that played
into it some Wow if the use of these
kind of satirical memes really didn't
have the full effect on the people that
were actually spreading them I have one
I thank you jump in here and clarify
it's my understanding that in autism
research the lack of empathy is a very
terrifying stereotype that okay often of
research but that is certainly the
stereotype and it's certainly like a
horrifying one at that thank you so much
for waiting thank you for that
thank you for the conversation Christian
it sounds like being a part of this
group filled some need in your life gave
your life some sort of meaning so what
personally did you fill that gap with
once you've left at 22 and what do you
think we can fill that gap with for
other individuals is it a social
structure we need or is it just um you
know better friendships and
relationships good question I struggled
for many years after I left because
initially I tried to run as fast as I
could away from my past I was afraid to
admit it so I moved I wore long sleeves
I'd made you know I tried to make new
friends
I'd to cover it up even though I wasn't
that person anymore I was not brave
enough to confront it and there wasn't
something like I had you know like what
like free radicals project to say hey
you know let us be you know your kind of
guiding light to get out of it there was
nobody I think what would have all the
things you said are important you know a
family friends but it really is about
replacing that identity community and
purpose for me I was lucky that at 19
years old I got married I had a kid at
21 I had another kid and by the time I
left you know before I was 23 I was very
intent on being a good father even
though I would wake up every morning
wishing I hadn't woken up for like five
years afterwards and then at the end of
that five years and I'm Christina knows
this because I'm sure
talked about it a hundred times but I
met a man who I had you know this black
security guard at my high school I'll
just tell the whole story because it
won't make sense without it at the end
of that five years when I was depressed
it was like ninety nine one of my
friends came up to me and she said I
don't want to see you die right go apply
for a job at the company that she had
just started working at small company
called IBM and I was like you're crazy
why you know like I got kicked out of
six high schools I never went to college
I didn't even own a computer like it was
ridiculous but I went and I ended up
getting this kind of entry-level job
setting up computers and my first job on
my first day for IBM my old high school
the same one I got kicked out of twice
its install their computers and I was
terrified it was eight years since I'd
been there but people knew me there
trust me like I had started a white
student union I had pickets there were
lots of brawls and fights and things
like that and I was terrified and who
walks by me the first person that walks
by me mr. Holmes the the black security
guard I'd gotten in a fistfight with
that got me kicked out the second time
and I thought it's over I'm gonna lose
like the one thing in my life I was
thinking about me right I wasn't even
thinking about him but I was like I'm
gonna lose the one thing in my life that
has finally brought me something and he
didn't recognize me when he walked by
but I recognized him and I followed him
to the parking lot and I tapped him on
the shoulder and he recognized me and he
jumped back because he was afraid but
then he listened and I said I was sorry
and he said that's not enough he said I
accept your apology but you're saying
sorry because that makes you feel better
right that's meant for you that's not
meant for me what I need you to do is
make amends and I've been doing it ever
since he saved my life and he was the
one who you know this is a man I
physically assaulted a man
whose life I made hell at the school
this was a man who said you know I
believe you and I have faith in you but
you have to learn how to fix this and
that gave me eventually
the courage to go out there and talk
about it thank you
you know this panel has focused largely
on extremist groups it seems like in a
lot of ways a larger problem as sort of
this lower case our racism implicit bias
and problems that permeate everywhere
from academia to healthcare to the legal
system etc given your experiences within
with extremist groups you know in your
opinion what can we do to sort of combat
these more normalized forms of racism
well I think the the number one thing
for me is actually to change
institutions I think it has to happen
within each institution because a lot of
the think you know this but a lot of the
science around implicit bias and
implicit racism is interesting but it's
very mixed right it's very very hard to
know how to change that the evidence is
extremely mixed a and B we actually
don't know that having implicit bias
leads to behaviors that are negative and
so I think looking at institutional
levels is going to be
important thing so how can you make
institutions more equitable more diverse
more inclusive I think is going to be
the the critical challenge I kind of go
back to my whole you know treat him like
kids thing you know I wouldn't shame my
children I wouldn't beat my children I
wouldn't disown them or you know throw
them out on the street I think my first
approaches is what I treat that human
being the same way I you know I treat my
children and and that would be my first
approach obviously some people don't
respond to to to being compassionate but
it's always it's always really worked
for me to be honest is you know it
disarms them because they expect me to
be aggressive they expect me to want to
tear their head off the minute they see
me they're like oh you know like this
guy is gonna be trouble and they're
really surprised when I just like hey
how's it going you know and and I sit
there and I listen to them and and after
a while they know that they're what
they're saying is not getting to me so
they stop saying it and you know I'm not
suggesting you know we all go out and
start hugging Nazis or anything like
that but to be honest with you it really
if we can get being if we can understand
that the ideology is just there to allow
them to do what they're doing and it
isn't the reason why they're doing what
they're doing that was like the the most
important thing for me to realize is
they're not they weren't born Nazis they
didn't come out of the womb with an
armband they you know they learned it at
some point and if they learned it they
can unlearn it and you know I mean even
somebody like and I hate to say this but
even somebody like a Dylan roof didn't
wasn't born a murderer he six months
maybe eight months before that was
probably you know watching The Brady
Bunch I mean like you know what I mean
like we
to stop thinking of people as month they
do monstrous things but they're not
monsters they do them for a reason and
that's usually because of what they've
experienced in their lives it sounds
like it's a very difficult thing to
create solutions for people that are
guided into extremism solutions that do
not rely on communities of color doing
back-breaking and dehumanizing work that
is there how do you feel about that
meaning so meaning they have to so
placing the burden on people who are
oppressed to explain and persuade is
that the question right there is a very
long history of people of color doing
the work of trying to end racism without
having a large backing by by white
people in general and so to create
solutions for in terms of these
extremist contexts without placing that
on the back of people who are already
oppressed a mutant how do how do you do
that I guess is my question well I think
one is empowering more people like
Christian Right we can do that work
without burdening people who are
suffering from that kind of ideology and
then so I think some of that is just
we're creating more Christians no not in
a religious sense okay more people like
you right so who can you train not and
for us as kind of researchers is what
can we take the essential components of
what you do and give it to you Christina
and say you go talk to white radicals
and see what happens yeah I mean I think
it's I am just one small piece of the
puzzle it really does take a team of you
know psychologists and researchers and
and you know lay people who do job
training I mean it really it has to be a
village you know anybody can do what I
do because it's not ideological I don't
go in there and you know I have
psychologists all the time that I refer
people
- you're like I cannot take your patient
I don't understand the ideology I'm like
good I don't want you to even talk about
it this is not the I'm not that's not a
debate session this is about you
understanding why that human being is
broken and not about what they're saying
so this is really something everybody
can do now I may have you know an extra
superpower because I used to be one of
them and and I have credibility and
their words don't maybe don't affect me
as much as they do you because I used to
say them and they certainly have a you
know very strong power and I'm not
diminishing them but I've been able to
sit through these things and that is
what does that's the only thing that
gives me any I don't even want to call
it an edge because I'd lack in so many
other places right anybody can do this
it really is about human connection
as something as the other and the
breakfast and a party Society
reach out to certain people
and I just want to say too it's not just
about the intervention part about
pulling people out I really we need to
start to use an analogy we have to treat
it like polio right we have to treat
those who are sick which is what I do
but we also have to inoculate the
population from getting sick otherwise
it's gonna be like pulling sand out of a
hole in the beach just gonna keep
filling yeah so prevention is very
important which is why I keep stressing
the fact that it really we have to train
the future generations to kind of weed
this out of our system we really have to
stop failing our young people and we
have to give them jobs we have to make
school affordable we have to make it not
life-threatening to not have a job
without health insurance we have to
there are lots of things that we need to
do we need to make sure that young black
men are being killed in the streets all
of these things kind of affect each
other right okay if there aren't any
other questions
if you have another question please head
to a microphone there was one more thing
I wanted to ask a while back you said
when you're talking about just public
discourse you said that once we lose the
truth it's not coming back and that was
about back in March and it really struck
me when you said that because I thought
things were really bad back then but do
you what's your progress report now
since then do you think things have
gotten worse or better since so I think
my quote was you know truth is the most
important thing at stake right now
because once we lose it we're not gonna
remember what it looks like to be able
to go back to it I wish I had a better
report for you I think you know I think
we're more in tune to looking for the
truth I just don't know that it's
readily available you know truth is one
of those funny things I mean for some
people you know if I had a brother and
we went to this to different schools
growing up and they taught him that two
and two plus equals five and the school
I went to you for my whole life they
taught me two and two plus four equals
or we would argue all the time because
each one is our reality each one is our
truth right so truth you know is that at
what is absolute truth is there you know
there's not a gray area we need to find
out what truth is again
and hang on to it because we're losing
it there's so much information coming at
us right now
intentionally that we're being lost in
the satire the you know the fake news
the real news the you guys don't have to
raise your hand like it's cool it's cool
it's just open it's just awesome it's
not a problem well I'm not a woman I
mean it's true there are certain things
that I just never know about a woman
likewise they won't ever know about me I
do work with women
there definitely is there's a lot more
men in these groups than there are women
but the number of women is rising
because what they've figured out is that
you know it's not rocket science
young women bring in young guys right so
they've started to use women as the
propagandists they're starting to use
them to make the videos the recruitment
videos because it's it's not indifferent
and in that you know they're still
searching for identity they're still
searching for community and purpose
there are still potholes but I think
that the churn rate for women is a lot
higher because while they you know all
extremist groups do this you know women
are our future they birth our warriors
they're amazing we couldn't do it
without them but once they get in I they
treat them worse than their enemies I
mean it really is the most misogynistic
you know intolerant towards women I
really mean that it's terrible so I
think women figure it out faster that
they need to leave but they're also less
empowered to be able to leave because
they're conditioned to trust these men
and you know when they get in it's
anything but they are for the groups you
work with are there are there
differences in terms of peacebuilding
strategies that vary by gender yeah I
mean I think one of the best trends in
the peacebuilding world recently has
been to make sure that women are
involved in peace processes so one of we
know from research that women led
priests processes succeed at a much
higher rate which is great and probably
for a lot of the reasons the reverse
reasons of why we talked about and so
now there's a real push in in our field
to Center women in peace processes and
make sure they're involved so I know in
the Syrian peace process the UN has set
up a women's advisory board specifically
to advise the special envoy I know in
Israel Palestine there's now a really
exciting grassroots movement called
women wage peace that's that's working
very hard and so I think that the more
that that can be done whether it's in
the D radicalization space or elsewhere
I think that's I think women not evil
sorry to interrupt I think women are
doing some of the most important work in
the space you know there there's a group
from Mali I forget their name but
they're stopping you know young teens
from going into the civil war there for
joining Boko Haram it's it's very
important for women to be a part of this
because I mean they're already very
misogynistic right in these groups and
that's also part of the immersion is to
understand that women are what they're
being taught right it's this whole kind
of culture of you know toxic masculinity
that happens and yes movements that they
really need that immersion you know with
with women to understand
you know they're not what I'm being
taught there because they really are
filling their heads with I mean a lot of
these men's rights activists crossover
with the alright so many of you know of
other groups that don't seem like
they're racist groups crossover
ideologically with them and the
extremists have figured that out so
they're now starting to pull from these
groups thank you for your question and
then sort of tying that back to
Christina's point about the burden that
often positions oppressed the burden
that they bear in terms of being this
constant voice sort of like deflecting
take taking this time to like
internalize rather than react to to to
move speech that's meant to be to to
incite hate and so I think what I'm
trying to get at with this is just there
seems sometimes to be at least for me in
my own work a struggle between doing
what feels morally or high ground ly
right versus taking register to be
strategic and sitting with a problem and
not calling it out they couldn't and so
my question then sort of becomes like
sometimes the time period can get
uncomfortable like students are quite
the question of like how long do I sit
with a person before I can call out a
particular behavior if I really want
things
like does that make sense the kind of
question in like what is it yeah how
long do i school like this so I think
this is this is exactly why movements
are critical and why you need to have
allies and groups of people working
together because it's not in in the
formulation I think the the thing that I
often try and tell people and people we
work with is you don't have to do it all
alone you don't have to play all the
roles right and so figuring out a way to
share that burden and use people who may
not have to be particularly vulnerable
to doing the work of persuasion is
really important so I think you know as
a social moving you want to think about
building power and capacity which is an
excellent and exciting you want to think
about persuasion of your opponents and
that's a particular group of people I
think Chris and I are among them excel
at that and want to do that and we feel
natural in that role and then others
need to apply pressure maybe and do it
in ways that's supplemented but what you
have to do is think about the sequencing
without making it uncomfortable does
that answer your question to something
right to some degree and then I also
have a follow-up question simply because
so because privilege and power are so
sort of intersectional there might be
moments at which I feel okay I'm not the
person who's excited in a person you go
a power a position of power at this
moment but there might also be moments
where I have extreme privilege and how
do you balance being an agent or sort of
like an amplifying agent with sometimes
unintentionally or unconsciously taking
the stage too often it does just sort of
like when you end up being the sole
person who can speak and then you sort
of unconsciously be the only person who
does speak well I make a very conscious
effort to try not to speak I have to
stop myself sometimes because I want to
say something that I know is important
or that I think would be important but I
forget that what they're telling me is
actually more important I don't I don't
recommend not being honest with
know that there is a period of time I
think you know sincerity is part of
building that trust so it's it's about
maybe how you communicate it not when
you communicate it I also want to make
very clear I'm not implying that it is
the job of people of color to do this
white people created it we need to fix
it however it's hard it's hard not to
utilize people of color for what I do
because that exposure is so important
and I don't ask them they asked me at
one point I put out I had this idea like
okay who's a captive audience prisoners
where does a lot of radicalization
happen prison how about a pen pal
program from from people on the outside
who are not racist writing to these
racists who can't turn down their mail
right and I said that to people I said
hey who wants to write you know to some
Nazis in prison and I put it out on
social media it wasn't on like public it
was unlike my personal page I had like a
hundred people sign up in a matter of
like five hours and 90% of them were
people of color
I think the misconception is and
historically I think this has been the
case we have put the burden on people of
color to do the heavy lifting but in
this case I'm not I'm inai I go in right
I spend seven years there are people
I've been working with for years so talk
about waiting for that conversation like
I I've been waiting a long time with
some people right it really is about
people saying they want to do it because
they want to understand it's it's
edifying for them too right
how many times you get to sit down and
talk to you know a Nazi or you know an
Isis you form rights this person and and
certainly it's you know again don't go
hugging Nazis or Isis people but also
you know what are we gonna do we're
gonna just kill them all are we gonna
throw them all in jail we're gonna you
know ship them off to and I'm good
that's all the stuff they want to do to
us so we really have to think how we're
approaching
and you know it's not so much about
taking the high road even though it is I
mean we want to do the right thing but
it's about holding people accountable I
mean I always hold people accountable
that's the first thing I tell them like
I will work with you and you may not say
yes right now but I am going to hold you
accountable and you're gonna you're
gonna do it you're gonna take
responsibility for what you've done in
the past
and right away may not be the right time
a year later might be or even a year
after that so it's really about every
individual person and you know I think
just be honest it's hard to argue you
know we're talking about truth just be
truthful thank you so much this is gonna
be our last question and then we're
going to wrap it up thank you so what
actually defines a Nazi what are the
criteria because there's a lot of
controversy nowadays about you know
people being you know like an caps or
libertarians that's the only express
views but they get called Nazis you know
I'm just just wondering how do you what
what are the criteria that you
qualifications that your chances are
good even if you did call a Nazi and
that person was a real Nazi they
probably wouldn't even know how to
explain what they were okay that's the
truth it's that's a hard question to
understand because obviously there's
nuance between you know what a white
nationalist is what an all-right person
is what a National Socialist or a Nazi
is or what you know a libertarian who
has anti-government views who some who
now also adopts you know parts of all of
these different strategies I tend to not
like to use the terms that they come up
with right I know that they sat in a
room and said what are we gonna call
ourselves that makes us not sound like
we're Nazis all right great white
nationalist yeah pretty good right we
did the same thing we didn't call
ourselves white supremacists right
pedophiles don't like they call
themselves pedophiles I mean it's just
there's really not that much different I
kind of put them all under an umbrella
of whites
this right if you are intolerant if you
think that if you have a bias against
somebody else because of who they are it
kind of puts you under that umbrella in
my eyes I you know there's some nuance
and certainly when I'm dealing with
individuals I have to understand that
nuance but again it's not about ideology
I think you guys need to throw that out
the window it's really about why is that
person why was that person led there
that's why they're doing it
90% of the people that are in these
movements don't want to be there but
they're stuck and they adopt these
things and they're addicted to them and
they can't stop doing them because it's
the only lifeline that they have to that
identity community and purpose so when
we talk about like you know do I want to
go sit and talk to somebody chances are
good that person although they may not
admit it at first is really struggling
with their ideology think about it what
is there to hold on to right it doesn't
make sense it's broken it's based on
lies there's no love I mean what could
you possibly like about it do you think
happy people you know like behead people
in the desert No
do you think happy people drive their
car in - and I'm oversimplifying the
term happy but it takes a lot of
brokenness to be able to do that stuff
to go into the street and beat somebody
down because of you know who you think
that they are because of the color of
their skin and we have to recognize that
they're accountable for what they do but
they were also led there by some other
force and you know it's not absolving
them of what they're doing but I think
to understand how we combat this we have
to go deeper this is not up here well it
could be but it's not about the ideology
okay that seems like a good place to end
on thank you both so much for spending
your time
once again Christians both white
American youth is for sale at the MIT
coop for 20% off if you would like to
see events like this in the future we
would love for you to come see events
like this in the future the MIT
communications forum we produce six
events per year if you'd like to hear
about them please sign up on our mailing
list over here we have for the rest of
the semester we on October 18th we're
welcoming documentary producer Sarah tax
alert she works for the daily show she
has a documentary called
tickling giant simple profile dr.
opossum Yusuf who is billed as the
Egyptian Jon Stewart on November 8th we
have a panel with Eric Lander from the
Broad Institute and Maria Zuber who is
vice president of research at that panel
is going to focus on federal funding of
basic research so please come join us
bring your friends bring people you
don't like we don't care we just want to
fill up the seats otherwise hey thank
you all so much for spending an evening
out with us we were always very
appreciative have a lovely night
[Applause]